the best practices are easy AKA it's
easy for anyone especially all the a
plus students in our world to understand
all the feature sets of every platform
and understand okay this is how
Spotlight Works versus this is what
LinkedIn is this is a Facebook Carousel
it's not hard it's very achievable the
reason most people struggle and the real
answer to your question of How To
Succeed is do you understand the other
human being on the other side of the
contest psycho nature the psychograph of
who they are when they're consuming AKA
you too you are who you are but when you
are going in a stream of LinkedIn versus
when you're going through your stream on
Tick Tock you are contextually different
and are looking for different things and
are in a different mindset thus
rendering the content to need to be
contextual to that aka the three of us
in a boardroom meeting are going to be
very different than we are in this right
now which is very different than if the
three of us went to a favorite concert
we're just gonna be different